and Nevada's new director of Prisons
told the legislature he had major
staffing issues today James deserveda
testify to the assembly Judiciary
Committee he took over after the
previous director was fired when a
murderer escaped from prison was on the
loose for several days he also told
lawmakers he wants to bring in more
prisoners families former offenders and
Community organizers to help out and
fill Staffing gaps
I have to use those resources in the
communities because there is numerous
resources that the Department of
Corrections has not used over the years
for whatever reason beliefs of security
issues beliefs of uh that it's uh it's
not practical it is practical
zorenda said some prisons don't have a
single mental health professional on
staff he also said that they have
recruiting efforts out of state and even
in other countries to find even more
prison staff